[Music]
on October 1st 1949 Mao Zedong
proclaimed that the Chinese people have
stood up to become a peace and freedom
loving nation 70 years later has this
dream been realized a look at China
today clearly shows it has not certainly
China is not a freedom-loving nation its
mass crackdown on political dissidents
and oppression of religious minorities
demonstrates its continued
authoritarianism it is also not a
peace-loving nation it is building up
its military to challenge the United
States and coerce US allies in Asia
however in the last 40 years China has
achieved much China's economic growth
has lifted millions out of poverty and
propelled it into one of the world's
largest economies China has also made
great strides in technology advancement
unfortunately what has not accompanied
this growth is greater political freedom
I hope that in the next 70 years the
Chinese people
will eventually enjoy the promises made
to them in 1949 do you think the Chinese
people will really stand up to the
Chinese Communist Party let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI
[Music]